several stories in the Bible are just
filled with explicit sexual content rape
incest Genesis 19 Angels save lot and
his family from the destruction of Sodom
and Gomorrah lot offers his virgin
daughters to the men to be raped in
exchange for their safety edgy doesn't
really quite cover that storyline I must
say Ezekiel 23 20 graphic description of
Two Sisters engaging in sexual activity
with multiple partners Genesis 38 the
story of judah's son put to death by God
for wickedness and right before he dies
he engages in sexual activity with his
daughter-in-law who is disguised as a
sex worker
folks if this is actually the standard
the content and not whether it's
Christian content or black content or
whatever then the Bible must be banned
of course that is not the point of these
bills